Hello, everybody. My name is Markiplier and welcome back to West of loathing
We gotta turn in... There you go don't know what that's all about, but there you go and you can fucccccccccccccccccccccccccccccccccccccccccccccccckkkkkkkkkkkkkkkkkkkkkkkkkkkkkkkkkkkkkkkkkkkkkkkkkkkkkkkkkkkk yourselffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffff
Huh "looks like these things are still twitching better lock him up just to be safe" does it gotta go in the ghost cell
cell oh
They are oh the gherkin brothers sell weird goddamnit. I really wish I didn't kill those last ones
God damn it. I didn't mean to I didn't know there was any other way
That's not like i had an item or anything of those that was gonna Help me sneak snonck. Oh well
there's only one more so let me finish that up before I go anywhere else the Potemkin Gang come across a
Goblin hey, hey human. What are you doing in this place? It's ground my ground is stomping
What do you mean, you're stomping grounds? What gary talk to this guy. your boots how tall they are to looking at? Yes?
Yes yes the tallest boots
How is it such tall boots you have to having to winning them in a jelly stomping contest?
You're in the goblin chatter for a while about boots and jelly and now stomping relates to both of them
Okay, alright anything of interest a fellow of very interest would you like to hearing a more jelling stomping?
No, not at all. I got a guffin. What's a guffin what I do with a guffin. Oh, oh
oh
Genuine Tnt and sandwiches town Hall for an actual town
Peculiar, you duck into the outhouse to plan your next move while you're pondering you notice something weird  this outhouse has a back door
lets leave through the back door
WHAT THE HELL!?
OH
Hefty load.
the back of the jail turns out just flat plywood like a
Theatrical set the ropes are holding this thing up don't look strong
You can knock it over pretty easily, but you should probably hold off until just the right moment
Okay, alrighty, then just the right moment. You say well. This is peculiar and backwards and weird. Oh
Look a plunger this doesn't seem safe at all
You know what I'm pretty sure I'd agree with that sentiment alright. Hello, the bandit looks distraught.  What's the matter buddy?
I lost my belt buckle. Oh
Did you look near the sandwich shop? Oh good idea ill look there? Oh?
OHHhhhh   eeeeeek
Hello, hi, sir. No entry alrighty then whatever you say buddy. Whatever you say
Alright. Well, I probably shouldn't blow them all up. Did you look near the
jail
Yikes yikey you.
Get away from me
I'm not trying it the guy says sorry. It's really very condemned the sandwiches were terrible anyway
Oh, were they huh how peculiar
get away from me ah
Okay, ah he runs over whenever I see okay, all right. Well you all stay there by the real jail
I'm gonna go back and see if I can do something bout all dis
All right see in a second
see ya guys
I'm not gonna blow you up because that'd be mean, but how about I knock it over?
cut the ropes. bam!
Crash falls over on the real bandits alright. Okay. Don't know why they bothered to build this fake town nobody ever let me into it
weird
All right, hello you all okay. You dead here. You dead y'all dead
Oh, they're dazed and confused. Take them to jail all right. God damn it
I got everybody
Except aah oh hey good to see you know if you really cleaned up the area I plumb out of bounties for you does that?
Mean I get to be sheriff no, but I guess he could be marshal if you want. Oh, what a coincidence. That's my middle name
mark muffler  Sneaky Marshal fumperdink
humperdinck
Yeah, that's it. That's the one. Thanks again for all your help marshal you got it
Sorry about that bag of ears and bones
I deliver to you meant to make that living people, but you know how it goes. You know how it be all right
Let's see if see if this goddamn circus ready yet oh my el vibrator oh
All right, we got aliens
Whoa gary getting strong baby
bAm that'll that'll make it good right, okay? Well, I got some eL vibrato scraps
I don't have enough to get back to the guy, but
I'm gonna see about this
It ready yet. No, okay. All right. Whatever all right. Let's go forward we either go to the railroad Camp all right
what's got you stop now railroad people yipes
ouch the guys stopped messing with his watch and started eating jelly beans what you got there jelly beans yep?
Can I have one nope please no get your own well? I'm never well. I never
Where'd you get them?
Roy beans
House of Justice and Jelly Beans well that's bizarre
All right, howdy boss howdy Smee stuck again
Yep
Got ourselves one hell of a canyon to get across and no materials for bridge building
any idea this is an old mind town up north called bread wood they opened up a lumber camp after the mines dried up if
You can fix a deal with them for the lumber. We need I can handle the engineering side of things, okay
Where is it? Smee marks location of bread wood  camp on your map of course anything you find to build a bridge out of it's fine by
Me, but that seems like the simplest option can I build it out of bones?
Can I do that one of those pay telescopes this one is designed by a promising young artist named after munch
You pay your meat look through the telescope at the big canyon. It sure is big
It'll take quite a bridge to cross that thing that's for sure. There's gonna be a lot of bones. I'm gonna make that out of
All right, well let's go to bread wood because that seems like an actual town so that might happen
I might have some better stuff. Oh open it up
Okay, cool got a ranch pouch. I sure do love my portable ranch
You excited about that timflor that standing horse. Give you hope and dream for your future?
Hello, are you the Mayor? howdy mayor I'm mumflur fumpewrdink here on behalf of the manifest destiny railroad company?
We need to build a bridge in hurry, so I'm here to cut a deal with you for the real umber all right?
I believe we can scrape together that much wood well sort of down payment, or
Offering oh, uh I sort of expected you would just bill us you want that much lumber with no upfront payment
Are you serious I can probably offer you free train rides?
I do enjoy a nice train ride, but that deal would be a real problem, and I've already got some problems to worry about
The Mayor glances the list of problems supposed to on the wall of paces around nervously offered to help with his problems
Maybe I could help you well. Thank you
I certainly welcome any assistance you can how far my problems got a lot of problems?
look at the problem board you glanced at the problems board which offers a selection of current problems as well as dire warning with
which problems do you wanna work with
Dire warning wait. What dire warning
What dire warning missing mail overdue book logging permit soup shortage Skeleton raid stolen yeast milking bread?
I'll do the mail I guess our last batch of mail never got here
We don't know if something happened to the Mailman or what go talk to reginald in the bunkhouse he used to be a mailman
So we can tell you where to start your search
Okay
Alright, that's a lot of problems. There's a note last time a mayor let this list go over three items
We chased him out of town with this breadstick nailed at the top of his head right? Well, this is bizarre
Hi, you know what towns got into pot when the horses are drunk alright sure we'll go with that one
Well, well looks like some poor son of a biscuit wandered into town how to cake sucker wow jeez rude and baffling get used to
It we lock our custon here in bread would share fine, but cake sucker. We also lack our breads a bread related products
So I've noticed I'll buy a drink
Bartender pours a shot of something and slaps it on the bar in front of you. I don't get to choose no all right
Thank you. Thank you very much, all right
Howdy gary, oh hey another Goblin tellin Gary once about a place near here. What kind of place very weird place all seeing through it
Okay, all right. Well ghost what it is
Then all right cool just two friends reminiscing about good old times and occasionally showing one another their guns in a non-threatening way
Alrighty then oh all right then probably dangerous to interrupt this si si bartender for darts
Skies Grimsley washing dishes he notice you're looking and waves away, you irritatedly
Alright, we don't take kindly to strangers stranger. Don't need your kind around here. Did you say need or need?
Well anyway
Signed on the paint got no dots
Okay, what about the guy watching this is that muffin lover ran up a tab it couldn't pay off so now he air gets to
Wash Dishes some of them dishes. I've been saving for just an occasion. I must izzy owned
150 I bet you're even dumber and I soon but whatever you can tell him he's free yourself
Alrighty take good. Bye. Now. Hello. You're free. Huh, what'd you do a thing like that for I was just feeling charitable
I guess well thanks, but I don't know how to do pretty much nothing sip washing dishes nothing at all well
I can also wash clothes. I can play the washboard. That's pretty much it though
Well as plenty of job opportunities open up in dirt water. Why don't you try your luck there well, alright worth the shop
Thanks, Pal. Ok goodbye. I'm in
It's another Spittoon. I'm gonna take a closer. Look look this isn't mom and pops family funtime saloon
this is a dive bar in a dive town the people who drinking here are mainly drifters and
Desperados don't go splashing around in the literal scum of the scum of the Earth
I'm gonna seriously don't this is wrong and disgusting it is vile behavior
I have my face right up to the thing. What's it look like?
No, I'm not telling you. Why are you doing this to me?
I had to skip lunch today because I couldn't stop thinking about you and these foul spittoons
Splashing around la la la la I'm not listening you find nothing you're the worst person in the world ha ha ha I fell
I
Found something all right
Like a necrotic skin disorder I bet actually it's a pair of boots, so there Mr.. Delicate stomach
Boots great boots full abandoned spit. Oh they have a little new kind of Trench foot just for you
I hope they named it after you you're just jealous of my sweet new boot
three maximum ap that's incredible, I will put on my
Spit boots. I love it. I got so much good stuff. Hey, wait
That's not my filth with filthy porcelain cow there we go now I feel better. Oh
Jeez a little bit were these guys up to ask him the man with the black hat as a huge pile of meat in front
Of him the man with the white hat looks broken sad, what'd you play in Fellas Ferro?
But I wouldn't say we're playing. I say we did play until this cowpoke ran out of money. How does it work?
It's easy you bet fifty meat
And then you say name then you name as many pharaohs as you can every time you name one
I'll give you 20 me wait. What those are the rules how this guy lose all of his meat to you
He's real bad at it. I'll give it a try all right partner start name of pharaohs tutankhamun
Well everybody knows that one. What else he got uh?
Sniffing can free
You don't actually know the names of any more pharaohs?
sniff sniff ank and free he grumbles and hands you you're winning uh
Amendments, it's
All right zip them and that's all I got tables clothes get lost oh
Still mad about losing better leave them alone. Oh, there's a trading post. Oh wait
No hang on genius at work here fred wood trading post. It's a post
Trade with it
You got it buddy. I'm gonna get that I'm Gonna get punching
gizzard Eatin and drink foraging
Finally monkey wrench all right. I'll wrench ooh mushroom plucking
whoo
I want both of these borrowing. I have enough money for it and let me see wait. Let me read all these books read these
Foraging yes, finally goddamn it unfortunately while practicing your techniques
You actually squeeze the book and a book juice. Which it turns out isn't a real thing oh
Man, okay fine Brawny which increases your maximum Hp?
menacing mood thick skin crease your armor
I'll take thick skin
You conveniently pull
you pull even conveniently include a sheet of sandpaper out of the book and rub your skin with it until it's nice and
Thick you got thick skin then you try to put the sandpaper back in the book and approach the whole thing oh
Good stuff gary you get that all right delicious disc gary. I know I don't right. Oh, that's so funny alright anyway
uh
might be something I can sell for that uh the mushroom pliers ah
Okay, that's enough all right got it bam. Okay. I got the mushroom picking thing
That's good to know I owe you one piano. Then. How was it piano playing in here?
Well, that's weird all is not well with this well all is not well with anything the rabbit of that
Okay, what did they get here?
Flush it just for fun
I got a perk master of flushing zipping your toilet flushing muscles are in fantastic shape
Sure, okay, oh
geez oh
It's funny wash up ah much better. Hello, Howdy are you reginald?
Who the Fukushi are you names mum Fleur fun burning the Mayor's got me?
Investigating some missing mail said you can give me a line on where to start looking. Oh, yeah, all right
I gave up being a mailman a couple years ago
But I doubt they'd change the system much all the mail auntie dear used to go through a waystation just sound sweat sir here
I'll mark it on your map
All right, thank you guys. It's chilling by the fire must not be a very good fire this guy seems very focused on this period
All right, howdy stranger. I'm Hobart boober. You're what I mean. Hi hobart a mum fleur pumper dink
You seem like the traveling so mom doing a fellow favor. What's the favorite thing?
He's my only dream in life is to see an owl skeleton. That's quite a dream. I heard they got one at the petting
cemetery
but what patton cemetery
Is that what it sounds like exactly what it sounds like but see I ain't got the meat for a ticket
You want alone?
No, I got no prospects paying the back
But I got a camera, and I figured if you under the cemetery you could take a picture of their house
Skeleton and bring it back to me, okay
I'll do that. I got an owl camera. It's it's camera with an L shaped aperture
Okay, I discovered the patton cemetery
Okay, I'll be back okay. I'll be back. Okay. I'll be back
David I need better lock-picking. That's what I need. Where is my lock-picking ah damn it. I need a little more xp
I'll get that in just a bit ah I love this game so much. God David. It's hilarious. Oh
Oh, why are you dead Done watch Dunwich crew ttan?
Croissant Lebreton
What graves pass here too old to still be legible? Oh, I don't have this level of foraging
Damn it. God. I wish I was like a snake oiler instead of a cowpuncher cow butchered basic
Bitch that could be something so better anyway. What was I talking about?
Let's go to the let's go to the ghostwood first, just cuz that sounds interesting
What do you got it, whoa?
You might expect to just be able to walk straight through but the door of a ghost building
But some kind of Force is preventing you
I guess you can knock on the force knock your fist makes a distant Echo II plops
Up in the barroom door, but a ghostly voice comes out of nowhere howdy there fella new in town. Yeah
I was wondering if sorry I can't do business with you until you have a visitor
Identification card ain't supposed to even talk to you really okay. Where do I get one drive to town oh, oh
All the buildings in town are weird and hazy and translucent like all ghosts. It's a literal ghost town, okay, alright
Thank you. Ghost houses weird right never heard of a ghost anything except people
Gary was seeing a ghost cactus once yeah
It's one down the end of the street - how does the cactus die with unfinished business did not poking enough people?
Buy that I'll buy that what's this that's a ghost rock the ghost drop
Alright fine, then oh my God or the ghost down all
There's a regular cactus. Well the ghost of a regular cactus
Well the ghost of a regular casius with the ghost of a pencil stabbed into it
take that try to grab the pencil but your hand keeps slipping through it almost as if it's a
goddamn ghost oh
Looks to be the ghost of a town hall looks like a regular town all except you know the old ghost thing knock
your fist makes a distant echo app oh
You'll be needing a visitor
Identification card, I guess so I'll be abie to fill in the forms most living people have trouble holding the pages
You'll be needin another band
So if you're filling in the form can't you just use your own pencil I?
Will be but the instructions say very clear the applicant must have our number three bands. Oh
And number three number two the usual kind I suppose, but a number three percent 50 percent more official
We're gonna get one the dark part minh of requisitions. It's just a store you mean the general store
It's a little more specific these days, but yes all right, what about this pencil. I want it. All right fine office supply
Hello, sorry can't help you unless you have a visitor id but I need a pencil for nobody ID no supplies, okay? Well
We've got an issue
See the general store won't give me a pencil without of his er
Id no certainly not they're not authorized to deal with anyone who does live in ids
So how am I supposed to get a number through pencil? I suppose I could issue a temporary visitor permanent
You don't need a pencil for that one okay great. What's your last name?
last name its bumper Ding
Bumper ding my first tip is muffler
middle name, it's Marshall and
Sneaky it's also Marshall
Where are you from a little farm outside?
Boring Springs. I live wherever the I farm
Boring Springs never heard of it. What's it like?
Well, it's not much, so I miss it already
That's nice. Thank you. All right. How many bars are in the window the
adjunct Department of records yeah
It's a quiz to make sure you have actually been paying attention to and care about our little town instead of just breezing on through
7? you hear a sigh and.. oh. God damn it fine. Whatever one two three four five
Six okay six and/or ten if you count the doors all right Fumperdink. Mumflr. Marshall.
Boring Springs. Miss it. In the window. You got six. Correct!
All right, everything seems to be in order here, temporary visitor pass it expires in 11 seconds
What does it say? Oh, God, it's expiring help help help help
Last name: Fumperdink. oh it expired.
God damn it *yell*
Excuse me fine. What's your last name Fumperdink. Mumflr,
Marshal, boring Springs, I miss it, what? Six.
Let's see. okay. It's fumperdink. what?
Gotta do this again. Fumperdink, Mumflr,
Marshal, little farm miss it already. What six okay? Can I grab this I got it
It's a number four
Oh, it's a number four not a number three know something you wouldn't notice look at number four is like 33% more official, right?
Ha nice try but it doesn't work like that
Alrighty then nobody's home excuse me, but never heard of you alright fine, then stable
Can see go away your aren't authorized shoo. Well? That's rude, okay?
Sharpen a pencil ooh, I got a sharp and gauche pencil
Woo
Wait a sure I guys sharpened a quarter off of it. That makes it three right that works, right?
Write a number three pencil here it is. That's the number four pencil no, it's
75% of A number four pencil I see hMM
I don't see anything about this in the bylaws very well, I suppose you two. Let's get you started on that visitor identification
Thank God last name bumper dick first name blum Fleur mentally Marshall
Mum floor Marshall humperdinck yep, that matches what it says here good. Where you from foreign Springs heard of that here?
It's real crap hole all right. How many bars are in this we know the adjunct department of records
sex
Wait, why?
Why?
Bumper dink mum Fleur Marshall boring Springs. Oh in the adjunct department of records ah
eight
Oh one two three and oh
Ten correct alright everything seems to be in order allow me to officially welcome you to the town of ghostwood. Here's your visitor
Id thank you say was it called ghost witter yes total coincidence, okay?
Well, I got that now so good
Can't think of anything for you, shut up, all right
What can I do for you, nothing? I guess
Can I help you? I can't think of anything
Knock oh what can I do for you? I need a drink immediately
I don't know why I did all this beer whiskey beer all right just got to take your name down for the requisition slip
lasting for take
Birthday month ler Middle name Marshall let me match that against your video visitor. Id yep, that's fine. I
Don't have the meat for it
That's a lot of money for goddamn you
All right, I'm gonna end that episode here. God. Damn it. Oh my God. That was insanity, but I love it
So I'll pick this up in the next episode. Oh wait. There's something I can kill ah
Good let me just murder this real quick. It's uncool if
Gary's real strong for attacks, holy shit gary get them get it and get them all right anyway
Thank you everybody so much for watching big. God this game is hilarious
So thanks everybody for watching let me know I did in the comments below and as always I will see you in the next video
Bye, bye